i gave him a gun i gave him a badge
i gave him the training if he didn't
have the heart to go in
that's not my responsibility well that
was embattled
broward county sheriff scott israel just
two weeks after the deadly shooting at
parkland high school last february
refusing to take any responsibility
in the breakdown of communication and
response that could have ultimately
saved lives
and despite several calls for his
resignation from high-ranking officials
including governor rick scott sheriff
israel is still on the job
now one of florida's biggest newspapers
admits that it made a mistake and says
the sheriff needs to go
the sun sentinel editorial writing in
part quote
the sheriff fails to accept
responsibility for things that have gone
wrong
instead suggesting that things couldn't
have been better if he fails to
acknowledge that mistakes were made
not only by individuals but by his
command how can we expect a better
outcome next time
jonathan hunt is live in our west coast
newsroom with the story jonathan
lisa sheriff scott israel has been
fighting for his job ever since the
february mass shooting
at marjory stoneman douglas high school
the biggest issue beyond his self-praise
the witness statements that highlighted
the contrast between broward sheriff's
deputies actions
as the shooting unfolded and those of
coral springs police officers
a state-appointed safety commission said
sheriff's deputies
some of them at least appeared to take
their time putting on
vests when they arrived at the school
and took cover behind their vehicles
rather than immediately entering the
school to confront the shooter
coral springs police officers according
to the commission were far more
proactive
the commission found in fact that eight
sheriff's deputies heard gunfire
but did not immediately enter the
building
one of those was the school resource
officer deputy scott peterson
he of course was seen on video appearing
to hide behind a wall
he was suspended at the time pending an
investigation
and later resigned in a letter to the
safety commission wednesday sheriff
israel
highlighted policy changes instigated
since the shooting
but again defended his department's
policies
at the time of the shooting saying quote
it is the strong belief of this sheriff
that no policies no words would have led
to deputy peterson
going into that building now the
influential some
central newspaper which initially
defended the sheriff
is as you mentioned calling for his
removal from office
something parents of some of those who
died that february day
have long demanded now incoming
republican governor ron desantis who
takes office on january 8th
could suspend sheriff israel sheriff
israel
once the safety commission report is
formally published
the sheriff told the miami herald this
week he has quote
no plans to resign lisa thank you
jonathan
and joining me now is a man who has been
calling for sheriff israel's resignation
from the beginning
jeff bell president of the broward
sheriff's office deputies association
jeff thank you for being with us sir
good evening um so i want to talk to you
about the shift from the sun sentinel
sun sentinel
why is that important that is huge down
here in south florida the sun sentinel
has always been known
as a left-leaning liberal newspaper who
has defended the sheriff at all costs
almost in a
romantic relationship with the sheriff's
office over the past couple of years
so for them to come out and admit that
they've made a mistake is huge
and if you remember back in april this
year 85 percent of our membership voted
uh that we had no confidence in sheriff
israel we called for his removal
that action drew sharp criticism from
the sun sentinel and they wrote a
four-page
two-page full corner article against the
union saying that we were overreacting
and trying to extort the sheriff for a
better contract over the parkland
massacre
which was the furthest from the truth
well somebody in the last eight months
at the sun sentinel finally found their
courage and grew a backbone
and unleashed our investigative
reporters to go out and find the truth
and eight months later after our voted
no confidence of sheriff scott israel
the sun sentinel the largest supporter
of sheriff israel
has finally reached the same conclusion
that this union and the men and women of
the broward sheriff's office reached
eight months earlier
which is sheriff israel needs to be
removed from the broward sheriff's
office
immediately sir what goes through your
mind when you hear that peterson did not
go in that these other broward deputies
took their time putting on their vests
and did not go in the head what goes
through your mind
well you feel disappointed that we
didn't make the right decisions that day
but outside of the law enforcement
community you can understand
the anger from the community within our
own department
we understand why failures of this level
took place this day
when you have a sheriff who on november
4th 2013
intervened himself into our active
shooter policy and took out the word
will respond and replaced it himself
with the word may respond
it causes a disconcern with the deputies
responding to the scene
of what action they should take and then
when he publicly announces that we're no
longer a law enforcement agency
and we're now a community based law
enforcement
agency and where we're going to help out
the community rather than to
fight crime in broward county we're
taking the wrong approach
and then when his further implementation
of lack of training
and is stripping the money away from our
trading budget so that we spend more
time
in classrooms learning about politeness
and policing and we only spend
four hours a year believe that four
hours a year
practicing with our guns on a gun range
that we lease from the county
the nation's largest fully accredited
sheriff's office
which is the broward sheriff's office
does not even have their own gun range
or training facility to practice for
these events and i put the full blame
on sheriff scott israel for his
intervention into these policies
and for failure to demand from the
broward county commission
a proper training facility so that we
can better prepare for the next incident
which is just waiting for us right
around the corner
well sir what do you know about the
commission report any key findings that
viewers at home need to know about
well that will be made public on january
1st
we've made recommendations to governor
elect ron desantis
that we need to take better courses of
actions with our juvenile justice system
here in the state of florida
i can tell you this on november excuse
me on february 14 2018
nicholas cruz and nicholas cruz only
went into that school and pulled that
trigger which cost the lives of 17
people
but i can tell you that the failed
programs such as the promise program
and the lack of training and the
policies that this sheriff has created
within broward county
did not create nicholas cruz but it
certainly
created an environment which allowed
somebody like nicholas cruz
to flourish in and we are seeing the
results of the poor policies
and the promise program taking an effect
where kids today are no longer held
responsible
for the actions that they take within
the community well these families
certainly deserve
accountability and i think one of the
issues and a frustration for so many
americans
is the fact that sheriff israel refuses
continuously refuses to take
any responsibility and it really does
start at the top
as you laid out you know how does it
make you feel when you hear
sheriff israel just refuse to take any
responsibility for his actions or his
failed leadership there's one word to
describe the sheriff
narcissistic the sheriff believes that
nothing can be his fault
and everything that he does is purely
for political gain
this man has appointed a leadership
within the broward sheriff's office
that is incompetent at best their
friends
political appointments and cronies that
he's brought into this agency
perfect example jan jordan captain of
parkland on the day of the massacre
what were her qualifications that she
was a diversity pick from sheriff israel
or that she was competent she was a
great leader no she was not
and that was proven because she was
overwhelmed when the
very first minute of that shooting took
place that captain would have been
overwhelmed with a simple
traffic stop and that was the sheriff's
number one pick to go into parkland
as the captain in that district sir do
you expect governor this
incoming governor governor-elect
desantis to take action regarding israel
well i've been hoping for the past 10
months that governor scott would take
action but he's failed to do so
it's not an easy decision to do but it's
the right decision to do
i've made my opinions very clear to
governor-elect ron desantis he knows my
opinions
on the sheriff and he knows what needs
to be done to fix broward county
not just only within the sheriff's
department but there's other areas that
need to be fixed
so hopefully with a report that comes
out on january 1st
and then what's expected to be the fdle
report shortly after that
he'll have enough ammunition to finally
pull the trigger
and remove sheriff israel as the sheriff
of broward county
and replace him with somebody who is
competent enough
to be the leader of the largest fully
accredited sheriff's office in the
nation
well thank you sir our hearts are still
with those families who lost loved ones
heartbreaking story we appreciate you
being with us thank you